hey everybody doing another movie
retrospective this is a good one we're
doing today
george c scott george sees scott
entering the world of porn
sold and he's a religious george c scott
entering the world of porn to save his
missing daughter yeah and uh john milius
uh produced
this okay
and there is some millions [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know that's good
it's also
just
bizarre because it's like uh anti-smut
but showing you smut smutty 70s skanks
everywhere male and female in the
underworld l.a doing porn and
prostitution and bdsm and all this [ __ ]
and they're all portrayed as like
[ __ ] basically sub humans
well everybody in the sex industry i
don't know if i'd go that far
but because there are some likeable
characters in it but i think the movie
too uh to uh to an extent is actually
kind of drawing i mean the reason it's
called hardcore
is because it's making a parallel
between the porn industry and also the
hardcore religious beliefs that george c
scott and his people have i guess so so
and it's kind of pointing out his
hypocrisy as well yeah um so this was
written and directed by paul schrader
and i feel like it's one of the movies
that he doesn't that people don't talk
about um he said that it was one of his
most personal films it's actually kind
of about his dad he was uh raised in a
very very uh very fundamentalist like
religious background and uh george c
scott was based off of his dad but paul
schrader has he wrote uh the martin
scorsese movies taxi driver probably
most famously uh raging bull he also
wrote like this last temptation of
christ bringing out the dead uh he
directed the cat people remake which is
actually really good pretty good
american gigolo and auto focus which is
we should probably do that one too
because that's about bob crane and
that's from 2002. that's a great movie
so uh so he directed that one as well
but i feel like this is one that doesn't
really get talked about a lot and i
think that i saw this and it came out in
1979 obvious obviously i was too young
to see it like in the theaters and stuff
because i was only seven
but i think i caught it or parts of it
on cable like maybe in the 80s
and then i just kept remembering it
because of like the i think because of
like mystery science theater they would
always do the memes like turn it off
turn it off like they would always do
that which is from this movie so it just
stuck in the back of my mind and then
when i was perusing through to be the
other day i was like ooh they just added
it and i was like i've been wanting to
rewatch that because i think i saw it a
long time ago and i'm really glad we did
because this was like way better than i
remembered yeah way better than i ever
it was good it was it was good it was it
was entertaining i liked it it was funny
it did have a lot of it was not really
funny it's just funny [ __ ]
just
i don't know just gotta watch it i guess
i mean yeah
george c scott who playing himself uh
like he always plays yeah he's so shouty
he was like dad just i love jersey scott
kind of stoic he's perfect for this
though people were evidently afraid of
him you know uh
be on set with him he was just uh
george c scott didn't like hollywood he
turned down
oscars and [ __ ] and he turned down an
oscar for patton and it wasn't because
he thought pat was the fastest he he
thought damn
he he thought the awards ceremony was a
joke it was just a meat parade he wanted
nothing to do with it but he would take
he took on on pat and he took uh awards
from other
he was like the new york film critics
or something like that yeah he accepted
that one but he did not like the academy
he wanted nothing to do with them he
thought they were phonies
uh he he was also
kind of embarrassed
about being in movies and liking being
in movies he was embarrassed he was more
into
doing live performances on stage he
liked that i kind of feel like a lot of
really good actors have that yeah and i
feel like a lot of creative people in
general not just actors that you know
writers artists whatever um you have
some a lot of them have a a large
portion of like uh self-loathing and
it's telling yourself if you're
successful you kind of feel guilty about
it like you're faking it or you
shouldn't be successful yeah or you're
successful at the expense of someone
else he was described as kind of a kind
of a a stoic and brooding self-loathing
movie actor he didn't like it but he
liked
he liked it but he didn't like that he
didn't like it he liked it
embarrassed to he enjoyed the attention
but he really he didn't want to be known
for it i get it he wanted to he he
wanted to play king lear and [ __ ] you
know on stage i get it like i said i
think like a lot of really good actors
uh georgie's got among them do you have
that feeling whether they articulated or
not which he actually did yeah uh but
another movie this resembles actually if
you've seen the 1999 nicholas cage movie
eight millimeter uh this is essentially
it's pretty much like that i think eight
millimeter is more about a snuff film
whereas this one is more about porn uh
but this does that this does have a
snuff film as a plot point as well
although it may have been a fake snuff
flick
well that's kind of like le yeah i mean
i guess in the context of the movie like
after i thought about it and after i
read some other analyses of it i'm
guessing that it's implied that it's the
real thing but
they don't really tell you like whether
it's fake or whether it's real or not
and like in the end it doesn't really
matter because i don't think that's like
the main message of the movie anyway
because what they're showing in the 70s
80s [ __ ] sex industries that they
were they were all scammers anyway they
[ __ ] scammers yeah so it
i suspect it was a fake
but
they were because they were spent
you had to pay a hundred dollars to see
it
to just screen it and then three dudes
at a time and i think it was a fake but
there's no way of knowing the guy who
made it who was in it
overreacted and got shot in the back by
the detective which in real life they'd
arrested the detective
for shooting that dude who ran away from
him in the back
um
you know just because you're a private
detective didn't didn't mean that you
were you know
out there [ __ ] catching bad guys it
was
it's a good movie i'm just i'm just kind
of critiquing it from like some of it
was unrealistic you know um
well it's just an action and i think
that it actually would be an adventure i
think it originally had a different
ending too i think that ending was a
reshoot which i kind of want to get into
so i am going to spoil it if you haven't
seen it it's on to be at the moment um
so you can go watch it for free but like
i said i really uh
like i said i've seen pieces of it
before but i was actually surprised at
how much i really liked this one yeah
there was one girl in there he he meets
and kind of he hires her to help
him find his daughter she's a porn star
slash peep show girl slash hooker
type deal you know and she's she's nice
and everything she knows her life's
[ __ ] up you know
and
she she in the end was like oh you're
not going to help me once once you find
your daughter you're going to split you
know that kind of deal he did you know
what i mean which is kind of oh yeah
the detective's like nah just should i
give her any money he's like
you know you don't know this world just
just let it go well i mean that was kind
of like i said that was kind of like
pointing out that his hypocrisy of his
character and like the belief system
that he held to yeah which like i said
when the rubber hit the road did he
really actually believe you know it's
very very easy to espouse certain
beliefs
religious beliefs but then once like
some bad [ __ ] happens to you
then all of a sudden yeah all bets are
off and i kind of feel like this it
didn't hammer that home too much but i
think there was a lot of that going on
in there yeah because like it was
obvious that the girl was kind of ready
to get out of that life and he didn't
[ __ ] get her out of there you know
like a [ __ ] show
and he didn't have a wife he could say
you're coming with us you can [ __ ]
rent a room upstairs i'll get you back
on your feet you know thanks for helping
me that's what i mean there was no
reason for him not to yeah but
you're coming back to michigan with me
but you knew that was gonna happen yeah
that that's the thing and i think that
that was pointing out
yeah it's like i don't necessarily i
don't necessarily think the movie wants
you to like think he's a villain he's
not a villain um but he's a complicated
character you know what i mean it's like
a character study of him and by
extension like maybe his relationship
with his daughter although interestingly
you don't see his daughter for pretty
much the whole movie she's only like at
the very beginning and the very very end
the rest of the time she's just like a
goal that he's working toward and it's
mostly like about him and like his uh
you know kind of going into the
underbelly of like the la porn singing
of the late 1970s i'm i'm a christian
mythicist and cultural christian i don't
believe any of that stuff is literal uh
i don't believe any of that [ __ ] really
actually really happened or anything but
i know that i know the
the christian culture real well and
the culture says that he should have
taken her
home with him
it got well and you'd think like any
good person she wanted to be rescued
that didn't rescue her that had spent
that amount of time with her yeah yeah
and that she helped him like find the
daughter he found the daughter right and
it's like you'd think that he'd be like
yeah and he had money he had he owned a
business he had a place like he had a
daughter like about her age
um you know i think the daughter this is
about it
the thing about it like the the woman
playing the daughter yeah i mean i'm
glad that they she looked a little bit
older but i think like the implication
was and i was reading another review of
this
where they implied that the daughter in
the context of the movie is actually
supposed to be 14. okay although the
actress playing her doesn't look 14
which thankfully but um i'm just saying
that i think in the context of she was
supposed to be 14 which is why it was
such a big deal that it's like you know
she's a minor like it wasn't just like
oh she's 17 so it's not that big a deal
right i think she was supposed to be 14.
i don't know if that's true yeah i think
that i think the the sex worker that was
helping her what i don't remember what
her name was nikki nikki yeah i think
nicki was supposed to be about 21 22.
yeah she was obviously like two years
older and yeah like an older woman in
the terms of yeah yeah but you know
still she said she'd been hooking since
she was 15 right yeah like that she ran
away
yeah and and she
basically she said she wanted to be
rescued he didn't [ __ ] save her yeah
which like i said that was like real
shitty that was real shitty that was
kind of the joke and he smacked her
around too when he was trying to get
information like he threatened to punch
her in the field like he smacked her and
then he was going to punch her in the
face yeah we had to use fear because she
wouldn't talk
he was just trying cuz she was scared
she was scared yeah
because she was he was getting in like
way uh deeper than yeah than he thought
you know what i mean although you know
just
which i can see how they were trying to
point out the hypocrisy because that's
kind of the
one of the big foundations of the early
christian church like second century was
saving people from prostitution and
slavery that's what that's how it
evidently grew according to
historians so
very unchristian not to take the hooker
with you
but see
in the context of it maybe we should do
like a little bit of a plot synopsis
like before we get too much into this
because this is some one of the things
that i kind of wanted to touch on so
basically what the plot of the movie is
george c scott he lives in grand rapids
michigan a very tight-knit community
very very religious it's dutch reformed
right yeah so they're they're calvinists
which if you didn't know they believe
absolutely in predestination they're
kind of one of those [ __ ] that
think like god like before time started
has already picked out like the elect
people and it's like nothing you do uh
matters essentially um because he's
already picked his favorite ones and it
doesn't have anything to do with whether
you're good or evil or not it's just
whatever god's whim is so well no
yeah it is kind of yeah it is kind of
like he already knows he
is it's god i mean you don't know you
don't know right but god already knows
and then your good deeds really aren't
much compared to the grandeur of god
they're like rags before him and all
that yeah and that humans aren't really
capable of any goodness
yeah compared to god is what is what
they're saying
um but no they're no people are saved
you can't just do whatever you want no
i'm just saying what i meant was um
since god already knows like obviously
you don't know so it's like but you know
what i mean you have to be your best you
just don't know if you're gonna you just
don't know and if you don't like you
just gotta suck it up buttercup um
because that's just the way the cookie
crumbles right i was explaining that to
uh
to to a a muslim friend of mine
them you know in islam it's all
inclusive you know everybody can go to
heaven and even non-muslims can go to
heaven and and you know everybody's
supposed to be in heaven well a lot of
christian denominations are like no too
no well some i mean most of them believe
that it's a limited very small amount
some say it's 44 000 that's it well
that's a jehovah's witness thing isn't
it there's a lot of them like that
um
uh depends on which denomination but no
oh
christianity really was
always kind of an exclusive thing
christian commandos we're the ones gonna
go to heaven you know we're there's
other christians now don't worry about
them they're not gonna make it
there was a lot of that going on for
centuries a long time you know they
wiped out the cathars because of [ __ ]
like that
you know christian sex fought each other
constantly
yeah yeah so but it was very exclusive
the idea was is only a small amount will
actually go
yeah so that's basically what and yeah
it was because they're not trying to get
to heaven
because there's a difference between
eden in heaven
because according to what a lot of them
believed and this is all forgotten
because people don't go to church
anymore they don't [ __ ] learn the
differences between all these
denominations
some of those denominations actually
believe eden will be restored on earth
and people who are saved during the
rapture will eventually just inhabit a
new eden and a kingdom of
kingdom of god that's on earth
and you get the garden of eden back
only some very small people go to a
small amount go to heaven and they're
like humans don't human souls don't
belong in heaven
um
that's a place where angels and gods
live and maybe moses and a couple of
patriarchs from the from from the old
testament or there you know but no not
regular civilians not regular even
christians you know
but so no there's a big hierarchy of
who's going where
jehovah's witness now joe's witness uh
mormons is even more complicated you can
get promoted into being a god and make
your own universe well you're such a
good christian or such a good mormon
that you become god in a parallel
universe
how's that for a reward
yeah but basically yeah so what what
we're talking about is that uh dutch
reformed the you know sect that george c
scott and his community is a part of uh
essentially believe in predestination
right
so um you get like at the very beginning
it's christmas and they're kind of
having a big family get together and
they're even talking about you know sin
and all this other stuff
at this thing now apparently his
daughter kristen who like i said looks
older she looks about 18 or 19 but i
guess she's supposed to be younger
um she's going on a calvinist like bus
trip and they're going out to that
sinful land of california and he's kind
of worried about it but you know they're
going to have like a bunch of chaperones
that's a bunch of other kids her age
blah blah they go
and uh at first you think that george c
scott his character's name is jake by
the way um you think that his wife is
dead because that's what he tells
everybody but that's actually not the
case which you find out later on you
actually don't find that out until about
halfway through the movie
so
uh so he so she goes off on the bus trip
now he gets a phone call
and somebody on the bus trip said that
well they took a trip to knott's berry
farm and she was waiting in line for the
roller coaster and she disappeared
so nobody knows where she went to they
can't find her so
he has to go out to la and figure out
like where she went to now original like
initially he goes to the cops the cops
care but they're just kind of like look
we have like so many missing persons
cases and a lot of these girls are gonna
end up dead yours probably just ran away
so don't [ __ ] you know get all upset
about it so he's like okay well he goes
and hires a private detective
uh now the private detective is played
by peter boyle who character has been in
a million things but will always be uh
the monster from young frankenstein to
me um but he's yeah he's actually like a
really good character so
so george c scott agrees to pay him 750
a week right yeah to look for his
daughter and like a a long period of
time passes but they don't really tell
you that in the movie like sometimes
somebody will say oh it's been
several weeks or it's been months or
whatever i think it ends up being like
four or five months like the whole thing
it doesn't seem like that but that's how
long it is
so
uh so this guy
uh the private detective
he finds somehow i guess i don't know if
he's a porn connoisseur or if he just
suspected that maybe she ended up in
porn and so he was like investigating
that avenue but he comes up with this
instincts he had
well he said that's true he did yeah he
had instincts and he's looking at this
real religious dude who says my daughter
would never do this and that he's good
and they're like yeah your daughter's
[ __ ] hooking yeah you know so he
probably yeah he immediately went to the
cd underbelly
of like you know one of those midwestern
religious
families that like their daughters are
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] and like took off
for l.a
and ended up in porn or on the streets
yeah and so uh so he finds this eight
millimeter film which very clearly uh
shows his daughter kristen
getting banged by two dudes yeah a
straight one in a gay one
yeah so it's just kind of like that's
that's where the scene like turn it off
turn it off because he like shows it to
him and he watches it for an
uncomfortably long time
that's her daughter dude stop it i mean
he does tell him to turn it off like i
guess he's shocked and he can't vote but
i mean
i don't know if i was someone's i don't
know i'm not someone's dad but if i was
someone's dad and like your daughter was
like in a porn i'd be like no thanks
okay i know she's doing this [ __ ] yeah
just turn it off i don't i don't want
that
image in my head forever because that's
never going to you're never going to be
able to bleach it face reality i guess
so then after that like he starts what
he has a falling out with the pi because
it turns out that the pi perhaps for
research purposes um is
investigating all these other porn
shoots and also uh you know sampling
some of the porn stars and hookers that
he comes across and he's like well you
know what it's research which like i
said but he probably could have found he
probably could have found her that way
like it probably would have been quicker
how you do it because i mean yeah you
don't want to pay the dude to just like
bang hookers on the side but he could be
getting some scuttle butt that way they
won't talk to you and so you spend money
on them right
and that's kind of they establish that
like later on
he tries to go up and talk they won't
talk to you and they're just like what
well you want a massage or you wanted
this or that you want wrestling you want
you know what i mean and he's just like
no i just want to know and they're just
like bye you know what i mean they won't
talk to you so yeah so he eventually
like learns that but i think that that
works good because it just shows like i
said he's this very very conservative
like midwestern kind of like he's not
wealthy but he's probably like upper
middle class he owns a business
and so he has no idea like about this
part of the world like this part this
kind of underbelly and he's not married
either his wife loved him and yeah and
you find that out later on and it's just
kind of like uh you know and he has
these like weird like you know even for
christians like pretty extreme beliefs i
guess
and he's never experienced anything like
this so he's completely completely out
of his element like completely out of
his depth so he has no idea how to deal
with this so like i said he just gets
mad and like moralistic about the pi
like i said doing some [ __ ] on the side
but like you said that probably would
have been the quickest way to find her
because just do a bunch of business and
get to know him and eventually fall him
with him
and then and then they would talk to you
because they would learn to trust you if
you just have this dude like that's all
up to you where's my daughter they'll
get the [ __ ] out of here yeah they're
like we don't want to yeah we don't want
anything to do with you so
so after they have the falling out and
then he goes through
in the scene where he have he actually
kicks the dude out of his own apartment
he cut the because he's george c [ __ ]
scott and he can do that
get out of here he's like get out get
out
this is my house and and eddie leaves
yeah peter boyle leaves he says kicked
out because he was hooking up with a
girl yeah
mind-boggling which like i said
if you're a george t scott if i'm on a
couch with some [ __ ] girl who's 22
years old [ __ ] really get it off
you're
this is my house
well the thing is and and it should be
noted too that it's like yeah he's
paying him 750 a week but that doesn't
mean that he has to 24 7 be looking for
your daughter i mean he's on the clock
he's off you
is going to this and he's like yeah this
is how i'm gonna find her yeah that's
but that but like i said i think that's
that was on purpose because it's showing
how out of his depth right georgie
scott's character was understandably
because this is not something he had any
experience with previously
so uh so he goes through like all the
pi's [ __ ] and he's like i'm gonna find
her my own self like i'm gonna fight i'm
gonna fire this [ __ ] and do the
same thing so he goes so he ends up
having to go so initially it's not real
successful because he goes into like i
said all these massage parlors
live section yeah it gets kicked out of
a whorehouse gets because he's basically
just trying to like strong-arm his way
through it and it's really not working
no one's giving him any information
and all this other [ __ ] so finally
finally he's like okay well if you can't
beat him join them and he essentially uh
goes to he starts going to like porn
shoots like he he says he's an investor
right and like goes to that one guy and
yeah so he followed with the gets on a
porn shoot and then he has the idea
and probably what is the funniest
sequence yeah of putting an ad in the
paper he's like oh like hiring mail
because he's looking for the other guy
that was in the picture the guys over
the picture they were in the picture
with his daughter like the the film
because he can't track the film down it
was one of those kind of just eight
millimeter real ones it was the title
changed yeah like in a hotel room or
some [ __ ] so uh so yeah and because it
was underage everybody was like i never
heard of that movie you know what i mean
because they can't legally sell it
so uh so yeah so he puts it out of the
paper like looking for male
porn stars and he also puts on a
ridiculous porn stash and a wig
and he's got like those crazy like
polyester shirts he's like this is what
a porn producer would look like
it kind of works which is kind of
accurate i guess yeah actually you
skipped the scene when he goes to the
damn official porn studio where they
were the bigger porn star the bigger
porn studio that they had going and it
was the dude and his [ __ ] assistant
this other guy and there was a [ __ ]
really good scene that was good those
two guys were [ __ ] funny as [ __ ]
and then later on um when he's
recruiting when he's recruiting for porn
stars one dude shows up where i
recognize this big old black guy and he
puts on a [ __ ] great performance in
this look he's only in there for like a
minute he makes a [ __ ] movie he's
awesome he goes my name is dick black
big dick black dick black
b-l-a-q-u
which makes it a million times better so
you want to hide it's just you got to
see it
he thinks he doesn't want to hire him
because he's black
and he's like no no no i'll take you
nutty
but he doesn't want to hire him because
he's not the dude he's not the dude like
the film like the skinny white dude is
that the skinny waist
what do you mean i'm not what you're
looking for and he goes i can i can it's
because i'm black isn't it
i can bust a nut ten times in a row i
could do this he's just everything that
he could do i could stay on this ride
it's great i can't remember what he's
been in a bunch of movies when you see
him you're right he was so familiar yeah
and i wish i could rocky actually i
think he might have been i think he was
one of uh
one of the trainers
that were training um
yeah you might have something there i
should have looked that up i forgot yeah
because he's only in there for like a
minute yeah but you see but it's a great
scene yeah he's super familiar yeah but
yeah i mean just the funny thing like he
has all these people coming into his he
just rented a hotel room and he's
disguised as a porn producer and all
these people come in and then there's
like you know another kind of surfery
looking dude who's like does gay porn
and then yeah he comes in and he's like
don't you want to see my dick or
whatever and he's just like yeah okay
fine okay
great
you know
like after a while he's just so over it
but then like the guy that was in
the movie with his daughter like shows
up yeah uh name what was this called
jism jim
jim that was his poor name like that's
you might want to workshop that a little
bit it's not a great porn and he's gay
yeah well not that no that was a
different guy that was a different guy
it was two that was two different guys
they were both they both looked similar
because they were both like blonde like
thin surfer types okay but no the gay
guy was the different guy than than
though okay than the guy that was
actually in the movie okay that was a
different dude but yeah they were both
gay uh well i don't think they were both
gay i don't know yeah i mean it doesn't
really matter yeah i'm just saying
yeah but you know
we i thought he was a woman at first
remember
in the movie yeah in the movie but then
he shows up now it's because it's real
grainy
yeah wearing women's underwear
yeah or well i yeah i couldn't really
tell because like i said it was grainy
and then i was like well in the 70s like
some of the men's underwear also looked
kind of like a women's underwear so i
couldn't really tell they were kind of
like you know ball hog
but he was supposed to be gay okay yeah
i mean i didn't really get that but you
know maybe that is i don't know but like
i said it wasn't as specific as it was
like with the other guy yeah who was the
other guy the other guy was like you
know he had done this he was trying to
have sex with him yeah for the job and
yeah he was like yeah can i show you my
dick and he's like yeah sure whatever
yeah yeah it's great so you know what i
mean which is like super funny but then
like this guy he's like he says
something that's very interesting to
george c scott he's like uh because he
shows the picture he's like i'm looking
for this girl like i think her name is
kristen or maybe she goes by joanne
which was actually her mom's name which
we'll get into
but um you know and he's like oh i'm
never working with that [ __ ] again like
she did some freaky ass [ __ ] or she's
into some freaky ass [ __ ] or something
like that she chewed up my chewed my
dick up or something yeah like i was raw
for however long after and all this
other stuff and george c scott is not
having it and beats the [ __ ] out of this
guy like he doesn't kill him but he
beats the [ __ ] out of the guy and he's
like look i don't know where the [ __ ]
she went to i only worked with it at one
time i don't even remember what that
[ __ ] movie was called i only got 25
bucks for it
and but he uh sets up with this other
lead he sets he's the one that sets her
up sets him up with uh nikki right it's
like yeah i think she knows like she
knows her so uh
so yeah so then he ends up going to this
other like kind of peep show sort of
place and meets nikki and then nikki
is probably easily the most likable
character in this movie
um
she so they kind of like established a
friendship and he's like look i'm not
paying the pi anymore i will pay your
expenses the same thing like 750 a week
or 900 a week or whatever for you to
come with me because they get like um
leads that i was now christian's in
mexico or she's in san diego or whatever
and so they're kind of like following
all these leads around so i think like
the heart of the movie is the
discussions that him and nikki have
about
uh she says she's a venusian like
you know planet from the
like goddess of love yeah that's yeah
but um yeah she said she ran away but
she's actually like a really likable
character and she tells him when he goes
into all this detail about his calvinist
beliefs yeah i mean she basically says
him she's like oh i thought i was [ __ ]
up and i'm like right yeah so
it was that whole thing but the thing
about it is that
um yeah so after a while like she like
she really helps him out
and
you know she gets to a point where you
know obviously she probably didn't have
a father figure or had like a very
negative one so she's just kind of like
she doesn't come out and say that she
wants to get rescued from all this
[ __ ] that she's been dealing with
her whole entire life but she does put
it out there and he kind of like
promises her you know she's like oh but
you know once you find your daughter you
know you're just going to throw me away
you're going to forget all about me and
he's like no no that wouldn't happen and
all this other kind of [ __ ]
i'll help you out but then like at the
end
when he does actually end up finding his
daughter uh and she's fine
but she basically tells him what we've
suspected all along that she's like i
didn't get kidnapped because he was like
no they took you they tell you she's
like what [ __ ] that she's like i took
off i ran away uh because you suck and
you know what i mean he didn't really
want to deal with that yeah and so he's
gonna take her back home and it's
supposedly a happy ending like the guy
that was doing the snuff film because
there's also like a little side plot
about a snuff film her boyfriend was
doing this enough her boyfriend was
doing the snap film and uh you know so
although like i said it the snuff film
looked fake but
to me the weird thing about it is that
they charge a hundred dollars to go see
this snuff film and then it's over in
like two minutes like they kill the
people like right away i'm like don't
you want to like make it last yeah i
would say i mean i'm not if it was a
real snuff film i'm just saying that
you you would think for that amount of
money you'd want to get your money's
worth the one that they show you that
they the one that they show you is
obviously not real it's made for the
movie well yeah but it was so
to me it seemed so kind of
fake that i think they were trying to
say that it was not a real snuff film
like in the universe of the movie it's
not a real snap yeah i think that it was
it was uh for suckers because they were
scam artists
that's what i'm saying they don't they
never tell you definitively whether that
was a real snuff movie or not but i'm
kind of suspecting because it kind of
goes along with the theme of the rest of
the movie yeah that that would make
sense that that because honestly making
snuff films and doing that that seems
like more trouble than it's worth but it
would be very very easy to fake it yeah
because and he didn't ask to see us
enough to just i want to see the real
exciting oh you want to see the real
exciting stuff yeah the exciting stuff
okay and then the real [ __ ]
thing you know right
so i think what it was is just to meet
market demand because you see this these
are sophisticated operations you know
where they had the dab dungeons and [ __ ]
like that those were all real sex clubs
and real they they shot them in all real
places yeah they're like
so they would just to meet market demand
come up with any old [ __ ] oh yeah
somebody yeah
charging 200 bucks for that you know
what i mean because like i said
why would you go to the trouble and
danger of making a real one why would
you kill somebody why would you take a
lot of money right because you can it's
just
yeah economically it doesn't really make
any sense
and then if the cops get involved you're
going to [ __ ] prison and and then
you're not going to make a lot of money
on this probably so it's it's a risk
better just fake it yeah and then
[ __ ] you can prove me and you got
hidden if the cops ever show up you've
hidden the proof like look here here
that girl's still alive yeah there she
is there she is
you know like with cannibal pharaoh
cannibal holocaust yeah i can't have a
holocaust a movie they [ __ ] brought
in i didn't kill them i promise here
they are right jesus christ right
but yeah so
so i don't know like in the universe of
the movie but
at the end um you know he takes his
daughter back you know because at first
she's just kind of like i ran away like
you never loved me and he's like well
nobody ever showed me how to show any
emotions these were like real cold and
controlling which i'll get into it a
little bit too
um
but he's just starts crying and stuff
and then he's like well do you want me
to leave and then she she kind of
changes her mind and she's like no
um
so he takes her back home but then nikki
is out there and she kind of like looks
at him and he's just kind of like
and then says to the pi it's like well
can i give her some money or something
and they're just like nah just [ __ ]
yeah just let her go you don't belong
here he says go back home so everything
that nikki feared about him
turned out to be right now interestingly
what i've heard i don't know if it's
entirely true or not but uh the original
ending of this which i'm not sure
because i felt like the ending of this
was a little bit abrupt
but the other ending but this wasn't
actually the ending that uh that paul
schrader wanted initially
the original ending was just gonna be he
goes through the investigation and then
he finds out i think that his daughter
was actually killed in a car accident
that didn't have anything she had gotten
into porn but it didn't have anything to
do with the porn industry and that would
have been like more again like
challenging his beliefs and like
predestination because like well that
was meant to happen can you deal with
that because i do kind of feel like
there is sort of an undercurrent of
him thinking that everyone's fate is
already sealed like what's gonna happen
to you that's gonna there's like nothing
that you can do to change it
but then when his daughter gets
kidnapped it seems like he doesn't
really have the strength of his
convictions because he's like well i
have to go look for her and i have to do
this and that the other so it's almost
like he's trying to
change the outcome even though he he
supposedly believes that you can't
change that like you can't change
people's fate you know what i'm saying i
guess so so so there's that whole thing
now uh so i don't know so i don't know
if that would have been a satisfying
ending and the thing about this one i
feel like this was more
um you know the studio or whoever
they're like well we want like the
happier ending where you find her and
like take her back home but then i'm
just kind of like well is that ending
all that much happier though because
nicki got [ __ ] over yeah she was like
the most likable character and kristen
who you don't even know because you only
see her for like a minute at the
beginning of the movie and a minute at
the end she's kind of like a blank slate
she doesn't really even get to talk
until the very end so you don't really
connect with her she's just like a
cipher or like a goal so i kind of feel
like
she wasn't that cool either yeah and she
wasn't really that cool so so i think
that that's kind of highlighting what he
was saying about predestination because
like nikki you know even though she was
a really cool nice likable person who
helped him out
she's still damned like she's damned to
have a shitty life forever even though
she didn't really do anything to deserve
it whereas kristen
has is gonna have like a really good
life she's gonna go back to the midwest
and
presumably go back to being normal and
it's like she doesn't really deserve
that either but then the thing about it
too is that even though they both go
back home
um nothing's ever going to be the same
between them again i mean they've
and they had a shitty relationship
before obviously
and i feel like that maybe is not gonna
ever be resolved because now you know
she's done porn and she's like seen like
gotten a little taste of freedom i guess
and she's kind of told him what she
thought of him and he's also seen like
the seedier side of life and
and her so he can't really go back to
like the bubble he was living in so i
don't know how much happier it is and
like i said i don't think he ever
grew or changed as a person because like
remember i mentioned before that like he
would tell people that his wife was dead
yeah you find out later on and actually
nikki uh was real perceptive she's like
your wife's not dead is she and then
he's like wow how did she figure that
out no she left them but he tells
everybody she's dead because it's easier
i guess
and more honorable yeah and i guess they
don't i mean they don't this is by
implication
just there's a couple of scenes in there
you're meant to think that she left and
the daughter ran away because he was so
controlling and like strict like i said
not only at one point later on does he
like
beat the crap out of that guy who who's
just like some low-level nobody but he
also hits nikki
and is going to punch her in the face
like if she didn't tell him anything
about it
and there's a scene and i wondered why
this scene was in there but then like
when i thought about you know the scene
where because he owns a company it's
like a furniture company or something
and there's a scene at the beginning
near the beginning where he goes and he
talks to that graphic designer who just
made him like a new sign or a new thing
for his out and he's talking about
oh how he's he likes it at first he's
like oh well i wouldn't have hired you
if i didn't want your input or like for
you to do it but then like after this
conversation and back and forth that
they have
they end up doing what he wanted anyway
not what she wanted so you can see that
he's very very used to like getting his
way if he can't like strong arm his way
by like literally punching somebody then
he'll just manipulate you into doing
what he wants so like i said he's a very
very controlling person in that way and
you're led to assume that that's why his
wife left him they don't never say that
but that's what the implication is and
that's why his daughter ran away you
know what i'm saying so i kind of feel
like there's a lot in this movie that's
going on
beneath the surface i suppose
um but yeah this is a really really good
one and i feel like when people
bring up like paul schrader's other
stuff this one doesn't get talked about
as much which is kind of a shame i like
i said i do think the ending was a
little bit abrupt and a little bit like
too easy of a
resolution at least i thought that when
i was watching it but the more i thought
about it the more i thought no that was
probably like the right ending to have
um you know so there's that whole thing
but
what else do you have anything else you
would uh like to say no i didn't read
into it that much it was just a movie
that just it was entertaining and yeah
he was a [ __ ] up dude not i really
wouldn't
i wouldn't have done it the way he did
it he made a lot of i wouldn't have
either like i said you can but no street
smarts at all well but that was that's
in line with his character i mean he
lived his entire life in the midwest he
was super super religious he lived among
other religious people yeah and he
didn't really have any experience
outside of that bubble yeah so like when
he was confronted with
cdsla in 1979
seedy as [ __ ] yeah it was seedious [ __ ]
i left fella in [ __ ] 81.
and i can live in [ __ ] carson
california it was outside it's suburb
outside l.a also in long beach
and i remember you know it was just
carson was just a
middle cla lower middle class or working
class neighborhood
it's normal you know uh
suburbs and you would see
those coin-operated
[ __ ] newspaper machines newspaper
machines they used to have back then and
they'd have it'd be porn in them
yeah and these are just
you know next to the damn
local
dime stores and grocery stores you know
just
it's not the way people imagined it was
not uptight at all
like you know not california during that
time during the 70s wow
well i kind of feel like because porn
had only recently been sort of
mainstreamed normalized i think it was
became legal yeah it became legal so i
kind of feel like everybody was just
like woo like the doors just busted open
like now you wouldn't have that because
you don't really need to like
everybody's surrounded by porn 24 7. 60s
and happened and then 70s hippie kind of
stuff happened and
you just go we used to go to like i told
before you know you go to sequoia or
redwood national forest go to lake
clarko which lake clark was i don't know
what that's like now but
when i was a little kid
go you know had my aunt take me down
there and everything it was [ __ ]
nudism half the time
just
teenage girls and little kids and grown
women walking around [ __ ] the men
just running around nude [ __ ]
swimming which i guess is kind of
innocent when you look at it you know
in a certain way you know just
the world was a little safer place i
think back in at least up in the
mountains it was but they were just
smoking weed
just
where's another world i don't know when
that's safe there was like all kind of
serious killers running around yeah no
they didn't know you just heard about
things on the radio you know certain
things happening but it was just
it was always like well that never
happened to me you know that's well [ __ ]
the thing about it is that shit's safer
nowadays but the problem is that you
hear about more [ __ ] more [ __ ] right now
because of like you know 24 7 we have
information at our fingertips all the
time whereas back then you were low
information so it's much easier to
believe that [ __ ] was safer even though
it actually wasn't because you didn't
hear about it as much yeah that's i
think the only difference but up in the
up in the four up in the forest you know
like in sequoia it was all campers it
was almost like a community and it was
the families and friends and park
rangers park rangers had come up with a
damn
come up to your campsite you know
because my ants were cute you know young
and cute because
paula would come and [ __ ] you know
and uh it would attract all the damn
park rangers and they'd show up with
[ __ ] guitar and [ __ ] start and
they can't campfire and [ __ ] singing
rocky mountain high and they'd [ __ ]
give out [ __ ] weed
yeah
they had guns and [ __ ] they were [ __ ]
smoking weed and some of the park
rangers were females and [ __ ] yeah just
they had a good time back in those days
but yeah i mean if you definitely want
to see um if you want to see kind of
like a snapshot of what the cd part of
la was looked like in 1979 this is
actually a good one because
like i said they shot on location they
shot in real sex shops and real massage
parlors and all and real live sex shows
all of that stuff uh you know you can
it's just it's just a sticky sticky
movie
i can remember seeing stuff like that
but i was only seeing it from the
[ __ ] you know passenger side of the
car you know mom taking me somewhere you
know driving through it remember going
down
downtown long beach you know and seeing
like the pussycat theater which are all
porn
theaters and [ __ ] you know but i don't
think that's where all the real hooker
stuff was happening i think that was
more like uh l.a
that los angeles yeah downtown areas i
think yeah because that's where yeah
that's where this was right but you know
it was also kind of spread out in
downtown areas of other little cities
like you know long beach had some of it
you know uh i think that might anywhere
where there was damn military bases and
stuff because that was military naval
ship and shipyards that [ __ ] was around
there stripper club strip clubs and
stuff
remember used to see him
cheesy lights and [ __ ] bad [ __ ]
bad [ __ ] graphic design on things and
to see it
i forgot how cheap things looked things
looked really cheap yeah well [ __ ] was
cheap the signs and the the lighting and
everything you know and
just didn't have the technology yeah we
had crappy [ __ ] back then crappy yeah it
was like how crappy it was real crap
everything was real crappy and they
showed the interiors you know la
interiors inside of [ __ ] uh uh
apartments and i remember
you know we had friends that lived in
places like that how crappy the chairs
and the [ __ ] looked and the [ __ ]
carpeting and the
yeah it's kind of a time capsule
one thing the 70s looked pretty crappy
one thing before we go i kind of wanted
to address this a little bit because i
uh read a review of this from the time
from 1979
and the reason the reviewer didn't
really love it was because they thought
it would have been better or the or the
character george scott's character would
have been more interesting if he was
actually um tempted by the world of porn
um i'm not sure i agree with that though
i think it worked better i kind of
thought that was happening though
uh well
remember how his friend came tried to
save me says go back home don't tell him
you found the type of deal i thought he
was maybe [ __ ] around with a little
bit
i don't know if it was so much yeah it
wasn't real clear whether he was
actually kind of getting involved with
it or i don't think it was i think it
was more like he had just become
obsessed with
finding his daughter because of his
controlling nature like i have to find
her and i have to get her back more than
get actually like being like oh hey
maybe this is a new career path that i
could go on you know what i mean i do
kind of feel like maybe he was showing
up to shoot
that's true yeah but see it's hard to
say because he was just trying to get
information he was just like trying to
find her and he and he realized like
finally
which what the pi had been trying to do
the whole time was that he would need to
like immerse himself in that world to
actually get any information from
anybody because otherwise nobody's going
to talk to him
so i thought the pi was more uh uh more
interesting he was like you know he knew
all the hookers and all the porn stars
and stuff and he's just he was like you
know like he told nikki he's like what
are you gonna do you gotta stay here
what are you gonna do you're gonna go
and you're gonna get a job
yeah you know you're going to go
work it what do you see you got to work
as a receptionist or something yeah
cosmetology cosmetologist yeah which
like i said i mean if she moved
somewhere where nobody really knew her
she probably could if she went to school
but she would have ever put up with it
is what she wouldn't be able to put up
with that's true she was used to freedom
yeah running around and just looking
trying to make a few dollars every day
doing having fun you know she she seemed
to have fun with it
well the thing about it she there's
actually like an interesting
conversation that she has with george c
scott's character where
she says to him she's talking they're
talking about sex and he's just kind of
always like oh everything's on said they
sell everything with sex and blah blah
and she says to him she says something
interesting
she says well you know you don't care
about sex or sex isn't that important to
you because you don't like feel any lust
or it's not important to you where it's
like it's not important to me either
because i'll just [ __ ] anybody and not
really give a [ __ ] about it yeah so it's
like it's almost like two sides of the
same coin which was different she she
was indifferent about it so it's like
yeah they really were like their
characters were really interesting with
parallels so i kind of feel like their
their interactions were kind of like one
of the best parts of the movie i thought
and like like i said that's kind of
where the heart of the movie was but
yeah if you haven't seen this one it's
from 1979
it's on 2b at the moment i think there's
also been like a really nice uh blu-ray
released of it quite recently and i
think it even has a paul schrader
commentary on it he doesn't love this
movie he thinks it's one of his weaker
ones like i said it's kind of one of his
more personal movies because it's kind
of about his dad
but um he
they said that seriously um they said
that his commentary is just all like
criticizing his own work like man i
could have done this better i could have
done that better stuff like that i'm
just like okay but i don't know i kind
of feel like this is a really really
good one you know i don't know if it was
as good it's you know i don't think it's
as good as like taxi drive or anything
like that but i really really liked it
there's a lot of skill everyone says
skinny back in the 70s
all that cocaine man back in the 70s you
know
[ __ ] a skinny [ __ ] was called a skank
i think they started that that
terminology is is still priced on
effects i i think everybody knows
they walked around [ __ ] in [ __ ]
halter tops and [ __ ]
yeah that's what like two
gonna say bell bottom pants and [ __ ]
long boots she [ __ ] nicki did have
one cool outfit there's a black real
tight black jeans black sleeveless shirt
and those [ __ ]
tall knee-high [ __ ] boots brown boots
folded over with like a
yeah that was pretty this was good she
was pretty rad looking actually that
outfit you could wear that now and wear
it you can get away with it you want the
sunglasses and everything everybody be
like wow look what a fashionista you are
but she was uh she was uh would be
considered a skank juice gang
yeah but she wasn't she was a nice yeah
she's cool yeah that's that's no
judgment right
skinny cocoa
titties hanging out i mean everybody was
a skinny yeah
more like nipples hanging out
okay yeah like i said 70s everybody's
super skinny so they're all pretty flat
all right
uh but yeah if you've seen this or if it
sounds interesting to you let us know in
the comments and we'll have a discussion
about it and that will do it for this
movie retrospective we will see you guys
on the next one bye